my way of introduction I'm a historian
of public health issues which means me
owns anything these days as a growing
tribe of individuals through intense
interest and essentially what makes
bodies fall apart particularly on
population also what keeps bodies in
motion supports be put in place to make
sure the survival and viability of
communities I came through this not in
the ordinary way or many public of the
story as many of them to train the
public on schools are specialized
departments history of science or is
your medicine I came to this as a social
historian it was trained at Princeton
University by nell painter
the foremost social historians of
like southern experiences practicing
today that being said my lens to my
material is as a social historian very
much didn't look very much interested in
station organization by American cities
and I come to this someone who is very
much interested in the experiences of
black Americans in cities bday as
patients or people who experience health
divisions in a myriad number of ways so
for example how might one say in any
toxic today how would one experience
particularly disease what role is my
lovely this is culture
yes right as a patient for example
how else am I want I mean from your own
just you know just filmmaking how else
might we experience disease yes because
the caregiver right professional
right hello policymaker and you
organizer activist anything else you
seem to get extra credit for it oh yeah
there's very ways in which begin with
the experience disease and a lot of
these are socially mediated that being
said I spent the early part of my career
looking at that I just finished a book
on this trip tuberculosis and the Jim
Crow South which looks at issues issues
of housing and politics and urban belt
and present marital said his
introduction I'm also embarking on to
other projects one is a look at
caribbean migration to panama and issues
of health standard of living
and ultimately the United States Empire
then the other one which is more
teaching and one which I'll describe
this evening is about health history of
Harlem now but further introduction I
should save a few more comments I did
not come to this project and more or
less a traditional way that one might
arrive at a project which is very such a
thing traditional way so it might just
choose if i hook around and say well
I've kind of finished one thing English
move on to another it might be more
eager to say those as drafted into this
where the at the time is very
overwhelming about a year ago but now
finding evidence actually this might be
a great fortuitous development I was
approached about a year year and a half
ago by a bunch of older physicians who
practice here Harlem some since the
1950s which puts the gas mileage there
90s and many of them were connected with
Harlem Hospital which has a long and
storied history gurgaon community and as
a group these individuals were upset or
least concerned that there seemed to be
known effort to maintain the history
Ortiz to document and research mr.
Carlin hospital as a historian and as
soon as this would be a very interesting
history office incredulous as soon as
swollen was working life so I took the
phone call and I said look I look around
and see if it work about this number
come in touch with you I did this for
about in between teaching and your
activities it is for about a week
competitor is really a lamentable dearth
of scholarship I'm not quite sure why
I'll tell you why there should be more
as the time you see that basically span
out into when is now developing into the
Harlem health history project which is
largely a teaching module which will
contains about my research as well but
also waiting where students can engage
the Harlem community
engage history of Epidemiology social
history of a public health medicine and
ultimately political economy in what
remains the capital capital black
America by the way if you have questions
thus far please for any point you to
stick your hands
alright so that being said if you're
looking at a at the history of community
and his health issue community such as
wrong there might be several things
interesting for example education
training practices social organization
of black health professionals to
confirmation somebody said that going to
experience disease as a caregiver
professional and non-professional
naturally people tend to organize
themselves around this so if you're a
professional caregiver you might be
belong to what types of organizations
press right physicians organizations for
example
soonerlater is just what we have to do
yes L do we never know the caregivers
are other folks who don't
in health care yeah for example rent so
you might be organized to employers
organized through video what else if
you're professionals for a professional
organization unions very special
organizations am a dark nursing social
problems if you're interested in the
history of public health you have an
interest in all of these properly
because it's not just about physicians
in white coats and facial plane from on
a bed thinking for help it's actually an
entire complexity layered system of
networks if you're not professional
caregiver you might belong to a support
for anything right people families of
members have also for example his for
families of substance abusers Narcotics
Anonymous is a type of organization so
that's part of this there's other issues
of the end product almost health history
tuberculosis control does anyone know
what happened here Marlon early nineties
there was an outbreak will speak of her
ilysm there was an outbreak of TV here
it was a lot of moral panic about where
invited originating where it's great a
lot of people center here
are not much different from what was
happening in years before there are also
experienced send us a turnaround time I
love since we're closest mortality
there's issues of institutions was
issued issues about a disease HIV AIDS
brings a different child health
reproductive health policy and social
history etc etcetera lastly history of
addiction research therapy experience
all right the audience for the HP HP is
twofold in the beginning we're going to
start with student research and writing
activities will be undergraduate I
should say that a unabashed Deborah
coaching from a therapist glass and you
were interested in history these issues
certainly be welcomed into the project
submission contains a deadline that you
mention towards
after that is developed there will be
community engagements us to say that
I've been in discussion with health
professionals researchers here in the
area who all very much interested in
this history not just the aging when two
people who rash very active in the
earlier than careers as well now for my
own will with the remain of marbach make
my remarks would be will center around
one particular aspect of this which is
what I miss my own personal research and
that's the history of substances we
think of substance abuse presumably
think of our corner product but I'm also
interested in alcohol and tobacco as
well for those of you that quick story I
guess until you see the new dental
i'll give you the so much less dramatic
version carolina car which is that
heroin had been known in the United
States is really the term 20th century
usership who's currently limited to a
small group of people remains pretty
much invisible very much kind of touch
the same note my keys 14 0 piano very
much part of the daily lives of people
who suffer all types of agents including
surgeries as well as what we have
geology so there's this underground
system of addiction that's been around
since the late 19th century even say the
mid 19th century as well and this
escalated in the 50s largely to the
entry of primer cultures and
guess you could say a certain about of
juvenile organization the reason I'm
stumbling I don't misjudge about the
language because Lincoln obviously he is
able return which is from 1950s large
but certainly networks of juvenile
social organizations places where heroin
injury late 50s after the kind of
counterculture jazzy B's 1950s see it
loves new closet 60s the nineteen rather
early to late 60s in the early 1970s we
start to see in black youth culture and
problem in other signs this is a serious
problem largely because public health
and Holland community specifically were
on unprepared for this is something that
really no one saw this coming a lot of
the kind of substance abuse issues that
we think of today and we from heroin all
the way through that or
forms political on post World War 2 the
counterpart of the social economic
cultural geography of the United States
excuse me very principles that's
prostitution as roommates right there's
a closing and there goes probably two
main fights or concentrating though by
the way is trying to make inversions
here in Harlem it is
today's so many of those things are kind
of post-world war two phenomena right if
we really have suburbs and you think
about today we have those 1930-now it's
really largely a product of highway
construction policy in flavor cane urban
cool and this place there's some targets
for them to go into but a lot of a lot
of the disease a lot of addiction
epidemics of these experience are really
compostable 12 and the early one Carolyn
very congressional fair piece of all in
it hit very hard there's also another
quite a few other factors that money to
do you think about same post 1971 1974
are being that I think you've read
something about
all right what was going on
pick another guy turn right
in the form of for example
yeah I mean I'm sorry
please finish it
it's hard
that's right but I view the news I just
that
there was something over here
okay right so there's a their influence
of things going on these are all things
that make community-driven susceptible
to two substances it's not only things
it is a whole spectrum of time to
discuss throughout the talk but those
are certainly know whether indices and
in fact Harlem became so to speak the
kind of a canary mom now how do we think
about the history of addiction there for
many many years these people who still
today tend to think of addiction is
immoral fail right whatever you
personally might think of addiction
certainly as an intellectual exercise
blue doesn't help to think of it to
think of it
addition in such terms I government
perspective which is more ideological
and social epidemiological debt which is
say that we look at look at disease or
illness phenomena on a population level
try to decide when clothes and in
whatever tarts them all right so part of
this might be the idea of as discussed
here is displayed here socio
pharmacology Sam Friedman someone is
putting forth this idea when she defines
his attempt to locate drug use or
provider socio-economic context as
intersex was hastened with histories
theologies of individuals the social
political economic histories and current
realities of different populations
communities and countries the prophecy
from Algerians we just look at our
social causation of these patterns where
our concept of causation is not what our
forces will determine is to impact on
individuals but rather one in which
social structures and processes affect
the likelihood that
these various drugs this is what I meant
when I said confluence of factors you
can't just say that it's a hard and cold
fact that that declines in unemployment
will in fact cause or declines an
employment will attract cause large or
increases in substance abuse it's not
going to be on examples of places at a
pen writes graph not metallic a
deterrence and substance abuse really do
not move but it's a confluence of many
factors now it's fortunate that a view
such as this has a background there from
which i can draw thinking about the
Harlem community service oshio
pharmacological perspective looks at
essentially social cultural and
political and economic context right we
want to know not just who's using what
and what become stigmatized and what
goes criminalize brother we want to know
what's going on around
I think of addiction is part of a larger
social system all right that makes sense
all right good Wow so by Framing
substance abuse within patterns of
substance use for example we can at
least we signal part of this context
rajat lives to separate abuse from
substance use is only really to say that
abuse is really one hint of a special
for many people there's a big difference
between someone who goes home after a
day of work to be successful they are
particularly unsuccessful day and ask a
couple of drinks whereas the official
clinical definition of alcoholism this
one who eventually has to a more drinks
every day for some of us that may not
make much more different somebody if
your complete teetotaler might say
anyone if there's any drink is somewhat
dependent
but there's a whole spec and the
question is for for a social look
addiction where do we where to find
spectra why don't you criminalize some
some behaviors while we really we can
either that's part of
now in terms of social and political
economic context we have I mentioned
these authors here because I found
interesting is out trying to frame my
own a ques about thinking about this and
also teach this when I begin this course
next year one is a Robert Krol sense
idea was an anthropologist and he's
called for a way of thinking about
political economy of hiv/aids substances
funny meeting that what are the
structures that promote first heroin use
for needle news but also risky behaviors
with hiv/aids but also in a way that we
don't think of it as just evil
structures and powerless divisions
because at the end of the day a project
that looks in the history of Harlem must
look at his people you can't just
brought an entire community that's
effectively century local agents so we
have to describe some sort of the power
somehow agencies individual is a good
little with
I mean we'll steer between that cylinder
in this those two bulbs leave Mullings
and Allah qawali have recently done
study of reproductive health and gender
relations in our community they are both
anthropologists as well and what you
might think of this kind of surface on
the surface this is a study of
reproductive health might include three
to five subjects you would go through
the divider mystical that you would be
two covers what they found it's actually
something really working Lex washing the
dress are coming at it from not just a
demographic and someone ideological view
but also that matters week we're very
much in tune to to the cultural means of
reproduction and what we're really
bringing to bear is an idea at what
point do you think of a community as
being stressed over stress and in what
point do we thinks you can this be
Mozilla you might think this has nothing
to do with this your prediction but but
a theory i would propose is that a lot
of what we see in elevated addiction
rates of addiction is really just great
ways that people cope with stress so
anything that looks at stress therefore
very fun substance abuse and estimate
the topography like to venture into
later rocking any questions as far then
of course there's many times employee
loves work through all nine historians I
think she has done an incredible job
actually presenting my history and being
trained as their story there's a certain
amount of disciplinary shoulders great
much invested in my profession and she's
a she's a community psychiatrist is
brought to bear the idea of roots shock
that's to say what happens communities
would have displaced why am I think I
should be perfect
why I was a question of rude shock and
it's affected by the store population
so Christensen first place
this car
our renewable bank
Oh
talk about material effects
this carpets this apartment like Robert
objects
ah
oops
we really look for a class issue
so some other games as well yes at that
being you know a member of a place
population just adds like another
destruction so like so like you know in
addition to perhaps with the university
or stress in the dream I already like
you know but not not necessarily knowing
like where the roots are feeling like
you're rooted in a certain place is just
another stretch that she's added on a
population though there's
the desire of the fastest rate just
that's right this is an ongoing history
again a kind of post-world war two we
will taking anything of the vast
displacements of black populations
beginning about save what period given
what federal policy we talk about a
wholesale evacuation of displacement
question
right i mean yeah federal urban renewal
and destruction neighborhoods talk about
promotion of suburbs red light all that
from the 1930s onwards these are things
that press release brought to bear in
terms of a psychiatric perspective very
much interested away as a community
psyche eating or it's viable it's
possible responses and agencies and then
Kathy Coleman these are all individuals
that highly recommend his wife with him
up here Ross people like I said to
inform people whose work I teach even
though none of them are historians Kathy
code is written incredible book about
history of HIV in early years black
agent early for clay this book as far as
I know remains probably one of the best
histories of the night
capturing black politics and HIV ages of
political scientists all right so all
these are our perspectives that
certainly had some very all of us a wire
all I think that's kind of self evident
since I'm a class that focuses on from
but naturally it's the capital black
america new york city of La Soul Eater
public health practice research and
policy then of course there's a
university and the question of his
position historically with in Harlem
well as future me what does it whatever
its debts and obligations and these are
all contemporary problems at the store
sighs
for the Raider of my time going to talk
about what are the approaches that one
might think about for doing such a
project in the history of addiction
first of all can we talk about a
historical epidemiology of addiction we
might describe historical kinesiology as
the application of mirroring of
ideological methods to pass disease
without a tremor occurred on a
population level any any list of bottles
of causality towards might be used there
then the next question we can we
actually apply that to addiction we
think of epidemiology a population level
that certainly poses some challenges too
and we think about addiction for example
the ideas of contagious behaviors which
is something I'm particularly
interesting we have known you know today
we've known for a number of years for a
few decades actually that certain
behaviors are affecting take it's not in
a kind of journal dermalogica sense that
we think
in the sense that you really can't
become a substance abuser unless someone
unless you could initiate someone tells
you how to purchase heroin how to cook
it how to
choir paraphernalia that these things
travel by networks and that's why one
reason why sociologists approaching
interested in is there's a problem of
that though because we started thinking
about potatoes behaviors who might
easily slip into the kind of reactionary
rhetoric urban ghetto pathology right
much the same thing that has been
stigmatized unfairly for a good three or
four decades the other students there's
a kind of Optimus racer
wall thickness somewhere in there is
interaction between the individual and
social like I said before it's think of
it all the society and the kind of
proclaimed society explanation which
which I certainly had some sympathy the
ROG individuals of agency and then the
day we want registered in people
actually being hold well healed right
say they have no agency that you must
was probably all hope of that so there
are some individual packages personal
history and exposure like I said
behaviors are contagious and frequent
exposure intense exposure to them very
well I think
visual susceptible or community
susceptible to these the socialization
of personality information what coping
skills are we given by family and
society or culture around this to do
other things with stress other thing
take up substances yeah for four years
Sickology on the side have noted that
there's less rates of depression in
latin which is I think maybe put it's
got school about that for a number of
years that kind of a lot of those iron
age sometimes research for the last
people figure out almost patently
obvious we try to made like a new these
people sell many you know if you think
about addiction is moral failing but as
a coping mechanism in the face of other
stressors or very there other ways of
coping with stress which are unavailable
or unknown then we kind of think of
addiction consider it a different way
next your drinks after work you know
sometimes no fried food stress silo
factors that are cycle with an
individual there's also genetic actions
this is something I don't know much much
better a research on it but uh as- game
isn't amedisys believe there are some
angry disposition now societal factors
of course go too much broader ideas or
broader processes how much do we attach
a stigma or an acceptability to certain
practices it's okay to go to the bar
with your buddies after work and have a
couple drinks however certainly less so
two cops for pure methamphetamine all
right there's much stigma attached to
one but not as soon as the other what
are the chances of life changes with
promoter discourage substance abuse
where the nature of social net are
talking to historical questions all
these things happening processes are not
static you're on time there's
possibility professional social mobility
issue places we found what the research
indicates is that places where there's a
preschool degree social mobility
diversity of fatality arm of are
fortified against the type of substance
abuse matters that we might seen other
there's also the issue of comorbidity
which is to say that some addictions
like some diseases occurring addict
brother ones right raising rights
raising rates rising rates it's
worthless for example you often find the
communities we have a high serum
prevalence of HIV to agree much comorbid
with with crack cocaine in the early
eighties we found that the lottery
chasing crack heroin that the rabaa
question of a cocaine crack cocaine I
needed to be tempered with a skeeball
apparel so you only found a lot for
morbidity alcoholism logical abused
alcohol so I used to back
now there are how do we think about
these structures this is rounding the
bend here I just for an example this
isn't only way to think about this is a
number issue it's here in New York and
thinking about it I've been teaching
this is a the scholars Roderick in
several aisles have looked at what cost
rising rates of HIV cirrhosis and heroin
use
mortality morbidity in the 1980s and 90s
this were cute American with HIV and
also apparently in 1980s I mean the kind
of typical explanation for either one
this conditions might a bit what in
respectively maybe when we talked about
HIV in 1984 if you turn on the TV what
do you think you might've seen what were
the contradictions
eight right particularly the white gay
epidemic which was centered in the west
coast and then later on mr. expletive
bright black communities 8687 who's even
called grid that's where I gave related
infectious disease there was a stigma
that went when it was discovered that
that there was a smaller epidemic in
Haiti then they were brought on this
Doug really a moral panic I was high
risk individuals and then whether the
epidemic spreads election is 86 87 some
people would say well before that but
certainly that date we do is pretty much
being i started take a whole we also
added to that list in terms of the
stigmatized profile that's right or
intravenous traumatic specific right
what would ever Roger Wallis showed is
that there are other things besides
these other kind of individually focused
factors which which contribute to
disease substation your use of heroin or
or cirrhosis and it's burger most
investment as well and was interesting
as a tennis club which came out in 1998
is called a claim on your house is
highly recommended I've been teaching
incredible book they regard
epidemiologists who were there on the
scene in the 1970s in the late 1960s in
the city of New York embarked upon a
plan of homes called plan shrinkage and
the idea was that shrinking fire
services and Ziggler price were evil out
of building up otherwise so the hardest
hit were east harlem is south bronx and
one might think no not in a written book
that rates of fires might not have much
to do with heroin use or HIV
tuberculosis or cirrhosis been infected
shown quite graphically as you see here
that there there's a correlation this
basically shows temporally fires went up
and down in in New York City this is
from all read or visit these grafts here
call exactly same kind of soup epidemics
epidemics start here with very low
frequency they peak here then as people
either died all become for his surviving
immunized against a quality it drops
down that's interesting things were
looking at fires here are the arguments
empires actually follow an epidemic
pattern they don't just randomly have it
which is what policymakers might've said
interesting enough what you find is a
housing crunch people become more
crowded in houses the ones that are left
standing hence you have rise in grades
of some of the diseases eventually I
think that's where closest for example
at the same time when Houser left burn
this is a cirrhosis here a housing
crunch obviously cause a certain amount
of stress other people who experience
cirrhosis of course the liver disease
brought about most most frequented by
alcoholism you see high rates of
mortality particularly a spike in an
epidemic epidemic curve you're looking
at a very stress community high rates of
cirrhosis mortality and then intravenous
drug use overdose you see these areas by
the way I didn't explain but in South
Bronx these were the areas that really
got burned out right here by benign
neglect across the river you would be
east hall which is that in this map but
less similar process a lot of IV drug
use and of course at this period that
would have
the gateway or an entry for hiv/aids
there's no of Epidemiology we would look
at that lead such as GIS unpublished
other sources demographic analysis etc
to kind of think about our their
processes such as this that go on for
epidemics before and after the great
program 1969 1980 there's also the
intellectual professional history of
addiction which is has become polluted
inning of the top you might need to
think about how people were organized to
think about epidemics or to think about
diseases addiction or tuberculosis or
anything you know black to you this is
an idea that first directly when I was
approached by a retired black position
to remain organized amongst themselves
even though listen we're not practicing
and they were practicing on very minimal
overnight we see patients they might
have served on the on a state board of
some sort there's a policy extreme
edition
any of you know anything I think we all
make them about the history such as
policy was very flawed history leaving
us with a large largest industrial
complex derives from really the
technical term looking for is pissed for
drug money absolutely by occupational
just but these are things that history
of addiction community by the German
most okay and then finally there's the
social cultural history of a nation as i
said earlier to talk you cannot perform
this type of work that thinking about
what our community responses to these
health problems with the addiction or
any other up front so in one respect we
should think about where community
responses probably not in the post-world
War two ERA from 1950s this was
treatment barely wider be a woman who
who practice medicine
it kind of just fell into being someone
who treated hair on that note train unit
was there was nothing available on being
a community position people who come
here it's at this job it's monkey my
back how can you know she just quickly
did some research and soon had a virgin
clientele this she maintained until
early 1970s when harlem hospital opened
the first heroin treatment program at
home and only did so because a number of
community activists actually physically
said in the hospital for a week and said
it without the even told the hospital
opened the stuff these are these are
instances of your social movements
actually force policy and force of
professional organization evilman
institutions and professionals seem
loath to actually respond this infamous
group here is a group called the East
Harlem Protestant parish which in the
late 1950s to the late 1960s organized a
kind of treatment regime for heroin
addicts with varying degrees of success
but using a religious but also somewhat
social medical perspectives and liberal
organization these men of course you
have what the Black Panthers the young
Lords were doing over there all heroin
treatment legs as well as a global
Hercules's general about our studies
there I think that's a good place we've
all hope of giving you an adequate
sketch busy two years
more about this writing any type of
research relative to thank you I'm short
on time so maybe if we have maybe two or
three quick questions I'm actually
particularly turning about policy
history of an issue that we discussed
and in terms of law enforcement probably
people or found within a certain
narcotics team in prison or jail in that
their result of treatment courts and
drop on portions of parts of reports
that actually designed to address them
who are suffering from these type of
addiction
but I'm curious to know from you how
that didn't have these newer drug courts
or drug treatment courts been where they
now what motivated you to really
adequately addressing the issue this is
excellent question which to not reach
the boss an hour
I'm aware of what drug courts with their
function in terms of what their efficacy
is as I kind of I mean first of all I
kind of visit there's a durance prudence
policy institute shall not sure what
their effectiveness is a spar or on a
public health love what it's been I my
issue what I've just heard about people
who have engaged in what I've kind of my
only experience is that it's certainly
better alternative we're treatment is
available then more punitive measures
the old
you can just walk away
now whether or not is institution as a
policy has not supported of resources or
enough guidance I can't say that's one
of the things which you know what would
be part of the project research another
by the way also a large component of the
project is also world history so we're
probably talking with judges prosecutors
very elemental project that will have
who
these are a half in Colombo I don't like
apartments history of artists being
favored position so I'm such an evacuee
yeah well heroin started in the 50s with
jazz there's a certain type of
middle-class bohemian sociability to it
back then erin was a cheaper it was it
was more pure so you didn't have a lot
of a kind of communal dislocations that
typically attend I've been introduced
after say 1960s it was kind of a FATA
messing we're not addicted eventually
it's very dangerous from it's not
entirely addicted people manage it
wreck your life but uh what did not take
the toll Washington's the numbers of
people using it the nature of sentences
so that it would later on here's the
thing about 61 there's a shortage of
heroin largely because of rising demand
that also something happened with supply
they supply was cut off in France I
think group switching a lot of the cable
France during the time i think i'm under
problems there but what dealers soon
learned and this is what I've gleaned
just from reading the kind of the
literature with sociologists who writing
at the times in the newspapers they
learn is that you could adulterate here
it's still sell it had a very elastic
demand in the sense that there's some
people out there and take care of it in
that way no matter what quality or you
know how far they have to go to get it
and from their average my understanding
is where we started having them chopped
up prada food where we stopped to see
that kind of line where it goes from
people who imported to the person who's
you know
major distributor wholesale all the way
down to bagman to burst on corner and
each on each level gets cut up and
that's where another company is because
that when it's that adulterated that's
where we're looking at five percent
purity on a good day the high is very
short-lived and you're in the person
convicted is more or less constrained to
a life of making sure they have the next
cop next next time so from everyone is
no longer about kind of that
middle-class don't even associate Billy
then we have a heart for class and
collected nothing that note obviously a
lot of what a few minute less people
also became attic and also really hit
people who also economically my heart
rates as well after Pope disciples 1960s
push
Oh last push fire
the grass work and
this is basically follow the fire
yeah this was I mean of every few years
mayor of new york mayor will announce
the closure of a firearm house someplace
users a lot of communal reaction
particularly post 1969 to 19
center while people got it reason why so
much problems just in fire fire support
the policy was first initiated in 69 for
some people developed a warning new
government they weren't city hoping was
random operation which was also
responsible for not working on policy
and they were the one is specially
formulated his policy and shrinkage even
though many people protested at the time
and certain things would happen no one
in hiv/aids but people did predict that
housing shortages be caused from shop
and some other conditions in which
proved to be right today I'm not quite
so sure on a system level you know how
many hundred fires we have these days
what the scope fire support looks like I
can't say what's going today but those
that the main folks that book is really
1969 to see the early nineties of the
period of burning
see we start to reap the
as well as well as
okay thank you very much